what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime operor and today i will be
breaking down the latest
madness of the boku no hero story
including the complete collapse of the
hero society
deku potentially getting yet another
mysterious power up
and the strong possibility that
endeavour
the current number one pro hero may be
on his way
out since the very beginning of the boku
no hero manga
we knew that this was the story of how
deku became the greatest hero
and by the looks of it deku's moment to
become the number one hero
might come much sooner than we expected
if you enjoyed the boku no hero content
on this channel and you want us to keep
it going please leave a like
and comment it really does help and it
only takes a second
and if you're new to animal pro or maybe
you watch our videos but you haven't
subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications if you want to make
sure that you won't miss any of our
videos in the future
the only way to do that is to subscribe
hit the bell
and then select that option that says
all
finally this video will of course
contain boku no hero manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution
you have been warned the latest chapter
begins as
hawks and best genius the current number
two and number three pro heroes enter
endeavors hospital room they greet
endeavor and the other members of the
todoroki family
and they are very interested in
gathering as much intel about
dobby as possible as i mentioned in my
previous video about dobby's backstory
we still don't know how a young toya
managed to survive that fire
or how he came to be the villain known
as dobby
that is the final missing piece of the
dobby backstory
and hawks and best genius want to hunt
down
that exact piece of information how did
toya survive and how did he become a
villain known as dobby
about a decade later by the way although
hawks
is definitely recovering from his
injuries and his personality seems to be
back to normal
we have to acknowledge that he is still
severely injured
he is wearing some sort of medical
contraption on his face
that i assume is helping him breathe
properly and he is also absolutely
covered in bandages like so many other
heroes who took part in the big villain
raids
but despite his current condition hawks
is clearly eager to get back into the
pro hero game
and he is willing to push through the
pain and i'm sure that he is dealing
with a lot of pain
right about now when she sees how
injured hawks
is rey prostrates herself on the floor
and begs him for forgiveness for what
her son has done
but hawks tells her that there is no
need to apologize and he is clearly
uncomfortable with having someone
apologizing to him
in this way genius quickly runs up to
rey and he helps her
up from the floor this rey apologizing
moment was brief
and it certainly isn't super significant
in the grand scheme of things
but i decided to mention it here because
it does really show how guilty she feels
about dobby's actions
we can only imagine how any mother would
feel knowing that her son
became a mass murdering villain because
she failed to put him on the right
path before it was too late this is
truly tragic for rey
especially when we consider everything
else that she has been through over the
course of her life
and her marriage to endeavor when hawks
learns that it was not
dobby but rey who scarred shoto's face
it reminds him of his own difficult
childhood and all of that makes him
truly respect
shoto hawks abandoned his troubled
parents and gave up on them
and he simply couldn't face them again
after everything that they had put him
through
and yet here is shoto reaching out to
his mother and father
trying to keep the family together and
trying to make things right
when it comes to dobby shoto's resolve
and commitment to doing the right thing
is truly incredible and even though i
always liked shoto as a character
i now respect him even more because of
his inner strength
shoto could have abandoned his family
and given up on his parents like hawks
did
but he chose to help them face their own
demons in order to keep the family
together
in the face of the tragic truth about
dobby i think this is truly admirable
especially when you consider
that if he had been a different person
shoto could also have turned into some
version of dobby
he could have used his difficult
childhood and his abusive parents as an
excuse to become a jaded and sociopathic
villain
but instead of doing what dobby had done
shoto decided to fight for what's right
both in society as a whole and within
his own
family we definitely have to put some
respect on shoto's name
he is strong and mature well beyond his
years
hawks then goes on to tell endeavor that
the situation on the outside
on the streets of japan is an absolute
hellscape
the heroes have been unable to locate
shigaraki dabi toga spinner skeptic
and like 132 other members of the
liberation front
this means that they are all on the
loose and plotting who knows what and
obviously this makes the general
public very nervous on top of that
seven of the near-high end nomu are also
still on the loose
as are many of the prisoners who were
released during those seven
different prison breaks orchestrated by
all for one
to make things even worse several
important members of the hero public
safety commission have either died or
been severely injured
and after seeing all of this carnage
many pro heroes are simply resigning and
retiring
i've already talked about many of these
troubling developments in previous
videos
but basically the hero society is on the
brink of collapse
the general public has lost all faith in
the heroes
after everything that's happened
dangerous villains are roaming the
streets freely
ordinary citizens are arming themselves
and forming militias in order to protect
themselves from the villains
and in general absolute chaos is
becoming the order
of the day the situation has gotten so
bad
that the japanese government requested
help from heroes from
other countries but this process of
importing foreign heroes to help
preserve order has been slow
and messy the fact that the government
is asking for foreign aid
speaks volumes about just how bad the
situation has become
in general governments never want to ask
other countries for help
especially not publicly because that
makes them look weak
and ineffective the fact that the
japanese government
is now forced to openly ask for help is
a big deal
and this is going to further erode the
public's confidence in the government
and the hero society it is very
difficult for a political and social
system to survive
once the public loses all faith in that
system's leaders
and institutions so yeah this is not
good but hawks tells endeavor that now
is not the time to despair now is the
time to
fight as the current number one pro hero
endeavor has the responsibility to set a
good example
and rally the remaining heroes before
it's too late
thankfully endeavour is not alone and
hawks and genus
both pledged their help and support to
the number one pro hero
the top three heroes in japan are
teaming up
and together they will try to turn
things around before the situation
spirals
out of control realizing that he has the
support of both his family
and the other top heroes endeavour
begins to cry
again he is clearly grateful that after
all the bad things that he has done
he still has the support of these people
he is grateful that he is not alone
in this difficult moment even though he
probably thinks that being alone is
exactly what he deserves
after everything that he has done hawks
then says to endeavor that he cannot
hide from dobby's accusations
the reporters are out for blood and they
are demanding
a response from endeavor so endeavor has
to make a public response
he has to face the accusations head on
hawks even went to the trouble of
drawing up a draft of what endeavour
could potentially say
but there is one factor that hawks was
unable to account for
and that is one for all
during his fight with shigaraki endeavor
had muttered something about
one for all and word about that fact has
leaked to the press
reporters are demanding to know what one
for all is
and how it relates to the villain all
for one
hawks explains that in order to get
ahead of the media and formulate a
proper response
they need to know what one for all is
but
as we know the truth about one for all
is supposed to be a closely guarded
secret
so this puts endeavour in a very
difficult position
most people have no idea what one for
all is and even though we all know that
that is deku's quirk
deku's quirk is officially not called
one for all
in the ua records meanwhile bakugou
is still out there in the halls of the
hospital freaking out
because deku hasn't woken up yet he
becomes so obnoxious that his classmates
are forced to restrain him
and carry him away from deku's room so
that deku could actually have a chance
to rest and recover
on the one hand it's great to see bakugo
is feeling well enough to make such a
fuss
since we know that he had some very
serious injuries
the fact that he is back to his crazy
old self is a good sign
and it is definitely reassuring it's
also heartwarming to see how much
bakugou cares about deku
they've gone from having a very rocky
past which included bullying of deku on
the part of bakugo to being close
friends who look out for each other and
who fight side by side
against even the most dangerous villains
but with all of that said
bakugou needs to relax i know he's
trying to help deku by forcing him to
wake up
but dude you're in a hospital and you
still have serious injuries yourself
try to chill out for like 5 minutes we
then also learned that tokoyami and
kaminari have already been discharged
from the hospital
so that means they are both fine which
is awesome
hawks and best genius then show up
outside of deku's room with the
intention of speaking to deku directly
but ita is there and he tells them that
all might is
in the room with deku and he requested
to be alone with him
for now inside the room itself all might
is still sitting by deku's side and
holding his hand
all might can feel that something is
happening inside of deku
something is happening with his quirk
and deku appears to be talking to the
previous holders
of one for all in this very moment
but what exactly does this mean is deku
about to unlock
yet another quirk is he going to learn
something important about one for all
and its origins i'm sure that the coming
chapters are going to answer this
question
but i'm extremely curious about what is
going on inside of deku
right now and i also really want to know
what impact
this is going to have on deku once he
does finally wake up
is deku about to wake up stronger than
ever before
possibly with the ability to use another
quirk
since endeavour is now a broken man
whose reputation has been ruined by
dobby
and since endeavor is now primarily
focused on dealing with dobby
is deku going to emerge as the next
symbol of peace is he going to replace
endeavour
as the new number one hero we know that
deku is going to become the greatest
hero eventually
but could that moment be closer than we
think
with everything that endeavor has been
through recently and with his attention
now
focused on dobby could deku and the new
generation of heroes
take endeavour's place as the pillars of
hope for the people of japan
i mean if you think about it the older
heroes have lost
the trust of the people all might was
beloved but he retired
endeavour has been exposed by dobby and
he also failed to prevent the villains
from destabilizing society
and don't even get me started on all of
those heroes who are resigning and
retiring
but these brave young hero students who
risked
their lives against the villains even
though they didn't have to because
they're not even full-fledged pro heroes
they could potentially rally the people
and save society from descending
into chaos after he wakes up deku may
become the symbol
of the new generation of heroes those
brave young people who have not been
tainted by the failures of the older
generation
personally i don't think that deku will
become the official number one pro hero
in the near future
but with endeavour compromised and the
people desperate for a new
symbol of peace deku could end up
becoming the de facto number one hero
in japan the one hero who can rally the
people behind him and put an end
to all the chaos with everything that's
been happening in the previous several
chapters
i believe that deku and the new
generation of heroes the hero students
are the only hope for japan they must
replace
the older tainted generation as the true
representatives of the hero society
in the eyes of the people and that would
be the only way to rehabilitate the
reputation of the hero profession
before it's too late let me know what
you guys think
is endeavor too compromised to continue
serving as the symbol of the hero
society
and will he be replaced by deku and the
younger generation
of heroes also what do you think is
happening
inside of deku right now could he wake
up with important
new information about one for all or
maybe even with a new quirk
don't forget to share your thoughts down
in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more boku no hero content right
here on the channel please
like and comment it really does help and
if you're new to anime pro or maybe you
haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you can
also hit me up on twitter and instagram
at anime uproar a big thank you to all
of our anime uproar
patrons for making videos like this one
possible
special thank you to alpha sigma
disciple of lord
twego himself and i can't forget all of
our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above all
other clans including ingrata the world
a quiet respect pate heffa liam thompson
algetal dr cortman johnny boy draws
emperor otaku spidey life tinel baked
buddhist and tungsten tarkis
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers on hell cruise
anatoly kazotsky
joe stanton very gucci jessica califond
wrathlyn deora
alicia octor bonnie parks hinokami and
water the red-haired raven joanne garcia
jack watches anime fat boy games ted no
ted deadly saint matthew cruz
and anthony schreiber if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value for you consider supporting us on
patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you